[Music]
can anything high quality be bought from
a dollar store
anything of high quality so ryan here's
what i want to talk to you about so i
think we're maybe asking a question the
wrong question here yeah i don't mean
morally wrong i mean the wrong question
in the sense of like
can it be healthy to eat poop
the answer to that is actually yes
there's something called fmt's fecal
transplants right if you have problems
with your gut microbiome and your small
intestine or especially in your colon
your large intestine then there are ways
to re-seed your gut microbiome
by either doing a suppository of
feces or swallowing feces yeah and
but most of us aren't going to say
should i eat poop today right yeah i see
what you're saying now how how why am i
why am i comparing a dollar store to
poop well here
here's another thing it's pretty clear
[Laughter]
here's another article for you ryan it's
called five environmental and ethical
costs of shopping at dollar stores
when you buy something at a dollar store
you'll likely walk out having spent less
than you would have elsewhere you may
have saved money but you certainly won't
be saving anything else
because you're popping up uh because
you're popping up on seemingly every
corner or because they are popping up on
seemingly every corner it's not hard to
drop in for a quick cheap purchase but
unfortunately
we've come up with five
uh we've come up with five environmental
and ethical costs of shopping at dollar
stores that aren't listed on the price
tag
so what are dollar stores first off
family dollar dollar tree and dollar
general are some of the big names in the
world of dollar stores their main
business ethos is pretty easy to
understand provide customers with
convenience and affordability and i'll
even say this ryan that
these cheap goods
they benefit
both the consumer and
the
corporation at least ostensibly right
and in the very short term yes because i
can save some money on a cheap widget
that is probably going to break
very soon right now the question is that
i need that cheap widget in the first
place
and are there quality items in some of
these dollars sure i'm sure i'm sure
some things in the dollar store are of
some quality and they may last a while
yeah but the truth that we're going to
see in this article
is that there is a whole lot of other
costs outside of that that dollar and we
want to be careful with how we're
spending our time and what else we're
doing to the planet here so
it says
that these dollar stores are taking most
of our cities by storm in fact as
america's neighborhood general store
dollar general now has more than 17 000
locations in 46 states
they are offering everything beauty and
health supplies food and snacks cleaning
supplies apparel seasonal items paper
products and housewares they offer many
of the same brands and products at
other stores like drugstores and grocery
stores but
they do so at a cheaper price and i'll
say this an ostensibly cheaper price
right because as we'll learn here it's
not always cheaper yeah there are other
costs associated you know what's
interesting about that though like a lot
of brands start out in the dollar store
so like for example x body spray that
was a cheapo one dollar thing at the at
the dollar store and then it started to
get popular so now they're like oh now
we can charge more for this and put it
in
you know in the more expensive stores
yeah same thing with like mrs meyers
that was
a dollar store brand um soap now it's
like
and maybe we'll get into this a little
bit in the maximal but it's it's a green
washing type
uh company yeah that yeah that looks
healthy looks like it's good for you not
a lot of chemicals and yeah they they
charge you with that in mind uh yeah
they up charge you but uh yeah it's it's
interesting mariah has a just a
sensitivity to stuff so she's got this
app you could look up different brands
and it'll tell you on a scale of like
one to five or something about like how
how toxic it is
do you remember the name of that app
ew oh yeah ewg that's where i check my
tap water as well yeah yeah so like mrs
myers actually is um what is it like a
three or four
four out of ten
okay yeah four yeah four and five out of
ten so again like the green washing they
make it look super healthy but you
actually look at what's in it and
um it may not be as healthy
so here are five ways that
the here are the five environmental and
ethical costs of shopping at dollar
stores i'll say that one more time here
here are the environmental and ethical
calls five of them for shopping at
dollar stores number one dollar stores
hurt local economies
so that's a big thing that we rarely
think about you know and it's not just
dollar stores it's amazon walmart
etcetera i remember when ryan we were
kids and walmart came to town in 88. oh
my god and it just decimated yeah the
little sort of local downtown areas
right yeah and i remember in middletown
ohio in particular
you know you go down that whole downtown
there is now it's like one of the most
tragic areas it looks a lot like east st
louis or something yeah it's wild and
now there is a revitalization effort
going on down there
because but it was far enough away where
all these these big box stores opened up
and killed the local economy one of the
nice things about where uh bex and i
just moved up in ventura county i'm not
going to talk about the city just yet
we're going to rev
we're going to reveal that on a future
episode uh talk about the local
community but one thing i'll tell you is
the
the
there are no big chain stores anywhere
and in fact you have to drive like 30
minutes away to get to like a cvs or
walgreens but there are
what that does it forces me to support
the local caring businesses
and if i don't like one of the
pharmacies there's like two other
pharmacies right and so you get to know
the people i i met the local butcher
there recently and you know bought some
local grass-fed grass-finished beef and
liver and heart and bone marrow right
there in my neighborhood supporting the
local
economy
and one thing that we don't realize when
we go to a dollar store or a walmart or
somewhere else is we aren't supporting
people locally per se now of course
local workers potentially
but we're not supporting local business
owners and most of that money if you go
to one of these giant
multinational corporations most of that
money is not going back in to your local
community yeah number two dollar stores
are associated with negative health
incomes
even if a resident doesn't score a job
there at first glance the opening of a
dollar store in a food desert might come
across as a good thing yeah i would
agree with that in fact before we opened
the the grocery store the grocer the
non-profit grocery co-op in dayton
that's where a lot of people bought
their food interesting unfortunately
what most of that food is processed junk
yeah seed oils
and
uh all these preservatives
packaged foods and so it's
perpetuating this ease in the local
community yeah number three is
dollar stores arguably aren't even that
cheap while they sell
in smaller quantities that have
extremely affordable price tags for many
items particularly food items the price
per weight is comparable or even more
expensive than it might be elsewhere
washington post did an analysis found
the dollar that a bottle of
a dollar bottle of milk at a dollar
store equated to eight dollars for a
full gallon oh wow so you're actually
paying more
thank goodness i don't have to fill my
car up with the dollar store milk
right
i don't know it's pretty daggone close
here in l.a yeah that's true
number four dollar stores use a lot of
packaging and a lot of toxic products
because the dollar store is able to
shrink nearly any product and turn it
into a cheap alternative that actually
is more expensive than it would be if
purchased in its full normal size they
use they use significantly more
packaging than other companies so i
think that's something to think about
when you're buying these individually
packaged things you're producing more
waste inadvertently yeah and number five
ryan
dollar stores equal environmental
injustice
this brings us to a problem our country
is facing and dollar stores like these
certainly play a role in environmental
justice issues the individuals who see
the bright yellow dg sign down the
street and who rely on it for many of
their essentials are likely choosing
between food and rent and struggling to
meet their basic needs right i think
that's um
i think that's true when you see a lot
of these dollar shows they're popping up
in neighborhoods without grocery stores
right and quite often they are preying
on low-income people and so
while the prices appear to be cheaper
it's just like if i were to sell you
cigarettes individually ryan it's gonna
appear to be cheaper i'm doing two
things here i'm actually charging you
more
as opposed to buying a whole pack of
cigarettes yeah but at the same time i'm
also selling you cigarettes right which
are harmful to those communities in
particular right yeah i mean the
communities where you and i grew up were
really poor and we didn't have access to
a local grocery store real close to
where we were
and yet we had access to an equivalent
of a dollar store right yeah a sort of
convenience store with cheetos and
liquor and a lot of things that are
unhealthy for us
without the alternatives to the
unhealthy things yeah
yeah man it's it's such a hard cause
like i feel like i need to throw the
caveat in here like this isn't trying to
make anyone feel bad for shopping at the
dollar store or like any judgment but
it is what it is and it's
it's an important thing to note that
like yeah some of these folks shopping
they have to choose between rent and
other and food and um
man i i would dare say like some of
there's a certain percentage of people
that maybe that dollar store is
the only option they have with their the
income that they have that's right yeah
but i would also i would also add on to
that understanding like when you and i
were growing up we didn't have much
money we that very little bit of money
that we did have
we misspent it quite often on things we
didn't need absolutely now food we
obviously need and the question is do i
have access to healthy food and can i do
it in a budget friendly way and the
answer to that is certainly yes we have
to be intentional about that we did a
podcast on that didn't we we did yeah
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free